ron rivera getting the game ball after
the uh the win yesterday let me just say
this i
i know the nfl is doing really well with
covid and and i i i
that was kind of a troubling image to me
though this guy's getting cancer
treatment there's a lot of guys crowding
around him with no masks on i know it's
the locker room after a game but
look
can we stop with the coaches and the
masks anyways though like they're but
but
but here's i know with him chris i mean
yes but in that locker and this is one
of the concerns that a coach raised with
me they got the bracelets on and they
you know of course during a game they
don't but that post-game locker room is
still going to be a petri dish we we
just saw the glimpse of it and you have
a head coach who is currently undergoing
cancer treatment that will deplete his
immune system we got to be smart about
this and uh if it was a positive day for
the washington football team but i was
alarmed to see that and i know when my
mother was going through cancer
treatments what it would do to her
immune system and how careful we had to
be that was without a global pandemic
that was killing people by the hundreds
of thousands so i i want coach ron
rivera to be smart i want the team to be
smart i want the players to be smart and
i know it was an exuberant moment but
you have to be able to balance that out
i don't i don't want him to get sick
sicker than he already is but uh what
what they what they did yesterday was
great it was inspirational down 17
nothing just like they were up over the
eagles 17 nothing a year earlier week
one and the eagles came out of it
washington came out of it they won the
game
27-17 game ball for ron rivera it was a
great performance and it was a
dominating defensive performance chris
eight sacks now i know the eagles
offensive line wasn't great but still
doesn't matter
from that from that defensive front as
you pointed out yesterday five first
round picks and uh chase young and
company getting it done and uh man if
they can keep that up
maybe they're the best team in the nfc
well yeah i don't know if i'm ready to
say that but certainly it showed they're
going to be a pain in the butt in the
nfcs that that's right their front four
can can dictate football games they can
change a game and that's what it did
yesterday you know let alone again
i you know as much as i want to sit here
and praise washington for what they did
and hanging in there and all that i
still look at that game and go eh i more
look at it as the eagles just being
stupid and playing careless and i don't
know what the hell they're doing you
know one i would just like to say
there's too much on carson wentz you
know one he has to have a little bit
better of a governor or a break or
whatever to go like hey this play's over
i can't take a sack let me throw it away
he can be reckless that way but they
need to help him too
you know this is what happens to teams
when it's all about one guy all the time
it's all about carson making stuff
happen and after they ran out of a few
tricks of game planning and stuff the
first few drives of the game
you know it just becomes too much on his
shoulders and then therefore he's out
there throwing out routes when they're
up 17-0 into tight coverage and that was
stupid and i blame him too but i also
blame the eagles you know they gotta
like
they got to figure out the right way to
execute there and not do that especially
without a run game they have no run game
again and then you have no offensive
line yet you're dropping back to throw
every play against would already which
we know is a talented front four going
into the game so my issue is more with
the eagles and i don't mean to me say
that to be disrespectful the the
washington football team but that's just
what jumped out to me more than anything
yesterday
yeah and and look still the eagles were
up 17 nothing in washington found a way
to come back and win the game ryan
kerrigan who had two sacks yesterday and
became the all-time franchise leader in
sacks like frogging dexter manly and
that means a lot to ryan kerrigan
because he knows what dexter manly means
to that fan base
kerrigan said that when it was 17
nothing
they
ended up
like not giving up
once they scored their first touchdown
that was the moment they got their
confidence when
i think it was logan thomas catching a
five-yard touchdown pass from dwayne
haskins that was the thing that got them
on the sidelines thinking we we can
still do this yeah then at halftime
kerrigan explained to me what happened
and we've seen the reports and
discussions ron rivera was getting an iv
that was playing so dwayne haskins
addressed the team
and kerrigan said haskins said we can do
to them
what they did to us we can do this and
they bought in they listened to him you
know anybody can utter the words
but there was something about that
delivery from dwayne haskins the
leadership that he showed in that moment
and that's how you create a leader
that's how you seize that moment those
are the things that are never going to
show up in the scouting combine meetings
or any of the tangible how fast you run
40 yards in a straight line with no pads
on this is about rising to the occasion
when the moment
comes and dwayne haskins did that
yesterday chris and then they went out
and they got it done and look we can
talk about the eight sacks and i think
that's that's uh fascinating and i told
kerrigan yesterday you guys need a
nickname for that defense he said let's
do it a second time before we come up
with nicknames for the defense but i
think we're going to be there right
where we're coming up with a nickname
for the washington football team defense
a team that may continue to permanently
be known as the washington football team
daniel snyder the owner of the team said
that yesterday more days like what we
saw yesterday it is going to be the
permanent name of the team i got no
issue with that i like it i really do
i'm kind of down with it yeah what's up
football team in washington keep playing
some good football football team i mean
it was i respect the what they're go
what they're doing the way they're
playing you know dwayne haskins speech
he did stay calm and collected even
though they were down and all of that
but you know again
it's 17 to nothing and we're making
throws out on the edge we give okay it's
17 to nothing you just kind of said it
that first touchdown gave them the
confidence to go hey you know that was
the eagles they served it up on them hey
here's a 45-yard drive go score a
touchdown oh wait let me throw another
interception here's a 20-yard drive go
score a touchdown oh wait we're up by
three but we're gonna go for it on
fourth and four because we're the eagles
and we're just always aggressive
aggressive aggressive aggressive
aggressive and then you get sacked and
you leave him a 20-yard drive now the
game's tied okay so you know that's
self-inflicted wounds over
aggressiveness wrong approach to the
football game that way uh just in my
opinion and i think a lot of that eagles
coaching staff and that football team uh
that was not a good look for them i'm
curious to see how they rebound from
this
and maybe just for yesterday's purposes
a little bit of institutional arrogance
that we're just gonna show up and we're
going to beat this team yeah because the
organization's in disarray we just won
the super bowl a couple of years ago
even with all these injuries we got a
lot of of good players and we're going
to come down there and we're going to
take care of business and maybe they
they just got a little bit too caught up
in the idea that on paper they're the
better team and they did some things
they shouldn't have done and it opened
the door for washington to steal that
game and if the giants lose tonight or
let me say when the giants lose tonight
to the pittsburgh steelers by at least
six points because that's the third of
my best bets for the week i could still
go 201 in best bets chris you're one one
and one in best bet so go steelers i got
my terrible towel i think i have a
terrible towel right here i think it's
on the other side of the monitor i'm
gonna have to give it a wave before the
show ends just for good luck but if the
giants lose when the giants lose
washington will be the only 1-0 team in
the nfc east just like 49ers are the
only on1 team in the nfc west yeah it's
amazing but that's why we play the
football games it's still early as we
know
uh but what washington showed yesterday
was
if you become one-dimensional and think
you're just gonna throw the ball on
washington
get out of town that ain't gonna work
they consent you know when you have five
first rounders and they mix and match
who they want in there and whatever else
wow it's tough to match up against that
group it really is and when ryan
kerrigan's the old man like not as good
as the rest of the group he's that guy
that's when you know you got something
special there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports